[Musique]
moi j'ai vu ça de la dinde fumée
on peut pas se tromper avec ça
[Musique]
pour aller à l'école c'est toi qui l'ai
fait
des fois je vais arrêter
c'est la rentrée et qui dit rentrée dit
le retour des lunch très pratique pour
remplacer le jambon les charcuteries de
dinde se multiplient sur les tablettes
alors aujourd'hui on a décidé en test de
goût de tester quatre poitrines de dinde
fumée tranchée prête à servir les
marques royales sélections
la première fois que je fais un gros
test de goût
est-ce que tu sais comment on fait ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
beaucoup de gens qui font pas de la
différence entre le jambon fumé et la
dinde fumée ça se ressemble beaucoup
d'ingrédient principal qu'on va trouver
dans la poitrine de dinde qui est
présente dans tout ensuite ça va être
l'eau parce que c'est l'ingrédient qui
suit derrière qui a transporté les
saveurs on va prendre de la viande assez
maigre un très maigre on va la saler par
un procédé qu'on appelle par avec une
saumure
on peut pas trop enlever de sel dans les
produits de charcuterie le taux de
sodium est comparable dans tous les
produits parce que le principal apporte
sodium ça va être le ciel chlorure de
sodium et le sel est apporté pour le
goût oui mais aussi pour un rôle
technologique pour extraire les
protéines recoller les morceaux ensemble
et aussi pour retenir l'humidité dans le
produit
qu'est-ce qui goûtait plus
ce qu'on peut remarquer par rapport aux
autres c'est que la liste des
ingrédients est relativement beaucoup
plus courte
j'aime bien la texture oui pour faire un
sandwich tout ça là il me semble que ça
se tiendrait mieux mais c'est celui qui
est le plus haut taux de protéines mais
ça reste une protéine maigre arrêtez ces
quatre produits là ce sont différenciés
principalement par le taux de protéines
la protéine arrêté c'est ce qui coûte
cher et donc plusieurs de protéines à
l'intérieur d'un produit plus le produit
est cher et moins il y a d'eau à ajouter
à l'intérieur je suis à peu près sûr que
celui là qui est le plus haut taux de
protéines de tous et le plus dispendieux
à l'achat
[Musique]
le goût de fumer pas mal de fumée
c'est comme des morceaux de viande qui
ont été poussés dans un boyau et donc il
sont mis dans tous les sens donc il y a
pas vraiment de structure de ce qui
rappelle moi la poitrine de dinde à mon
avis pourquoi vous utilisez rarement la
dinde fumée parce que la charcuterie il
y a des nitrites qui essaient de limiter
la quantité nitrite que j'aime de mes
enfants
sur nos quatre produits un seul contient
des nitrites un additif qui augmente les
risques de cancer colorectal une nitrite
il faut pas en manger trop le nitrite
sert beaucoup à la couleur et aussi à la
conservation dans la poitrine de dinde
comme c'est pas un produit normalisé il
y a aucune norme qui exige de rajouter
du nitrite à l'intérieur comme c'est le
cas du jambon
[Musique]
ici on a le produit sélection donc ce
qu'on regarde par rapport aux deux
précédents il y a beaucoup plus
d'ingrédients dans le ingrédients que je
vais rajouter qu'on n'a pas vu tout à
l'heure la présence de phosphates sodium
et de caragénines va faire que le
produit va être beaucoup plus gélifié
[Musique]
le bleu me rappelle curieusement la
balle au monde
[Rires]
celui-là c'est le bleu comme fumer non
je peux faire le bleu le bleu il était
bon ben je trouvais un peu comme tu peux
la fabrication des poitrines de dinde
fumée il y a trois méthodes à porter la
fumée soit on prend de la fumée
naturelle c'est-à-dire on génère à
partir du brancy de la fumée à côté de
l'enseigne de cuisson on a le film
enceinte de cuisson ça serait la fumée
naturelle ou qu'on déclare fumé ensuite
on peut prendre la fumée liquide qui
elle est issue de la combustion du bois
qui a été faite à l'extérieur et en
recréer une fumée par atomisation donc
ça ça va être déclaré fumé généralement
ou alors on peut prendre cette fumée
liquide l'incorporer dans la saumure
l'injecter dans la viande donc là au
lieu de la mettre juste à la surface il
va y avoir aussi à l'intérieur de la
viande et c'est pour ça qu'on va
l'appeler soit arôme de fumée soit
saveur de fumée
[Musique]
quand on compile les résultats de nos
goutteurs on voit tout de suite qu'il y
a trois produits qui sont presque exéco
mais il y a un grand gagnant qui récolté
la moitié des votes c'est à l'email
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce test
de goût
[Musique]